Okay, I don't know.
I don't know if you watch that Ashley Madison fucking show,
but I binged it cause I remember that shit.
I remember that shit.
I remember that fucking YouTube couple with their fucking frozen song.
And he fucking swears to god that he took piss out of the toilet.
Like, diluted piss out of the toilet.
And he told her she was pregnant.
Like, they are just still fucking,
like, calm the fuck on.
But I loved it because for all the young women who think,
my husband would never do that,
no, we have a loving marriage.
No, blah, blah, blah, blah.
All the shit that this cute little woman is saying,
you know what I mean?
I'm. It sucks that she fucking stayed with him.
Sounds like he put her through the fucking ringer.
He's gonna do it again, probably.
Or at some point in his life he's gonna be like,
you know what?
I just can't like.
Like
when someone shows you who they are,
fucking believe them.
Believe them in every way.
When someone shows you they're a good person,
they like, oh,
a little bit of vulnerability.
Cling to that and like, okay.
But when they flip that shit and show you that they're a piece of shit,
like, oh, my god,
oh, my god, oh, my god.
That shit was like,
I'm just.
It's just so validating.
It's so. That's what it is.
It's so fucking validating, because I'm like, Okay,
so she chose a different route.
She decided to stay with him and work on her marriage.
And what does that get her?
A lifetime of every fucking memory they have is tainted with
if he ate some other girl's pussy.
He was fucking digging some other bitch out.
And then you're just gonna be like, sitting by the pool happy with him.
Mia, I hope you fucking see this.
I hope you fucking see this.
Cause then I looked it up
and then
they're still trying to get mad views on their fucking YouTube
using this shit. Like.
Like maybe re.
Like take a different fucking path on the journey sometimes.
Oh my god, I'm just.
That couple blows my fucking mind and.